in this video I want to talk a little
bit about DNA and RNA structure
specifically how to draw nucleic acids
the new tunity nucleic acids that we've
learned about our DNA and RNA so we've
talked previously about
deoxyribonucleotides and ribonucleotides
so now we're going to use that knowledge
and apply it as far as being able to
draw nucleic acids so let's just do this
really simply think about how would we
draw the DNA nucleotide 5 prime to 3
prime T C so this means we would have
two nucleotides connected together to
specifically
deoxynucleotides DNA with the 5 prime
end the five prime phosphate group is
going to be on the thymine and the three
prime LH send me on the cytosine so how
do these two actually connect so I've
drawn here I've drawn a dtmp so this is
of course the deoxyribose sugar I know
that because the two prime carbon has
just the hydrogen here and the five
prime phosphate here is just just a
phosphate and over here we have the base
thymine now this is needs to be
connected to a cytosine nucleotide now
this here is what we call ad a/d ntp
specifically this is dctp so a deoxy you
nucleotide triphosphate and it's deoxy
because of the the two prime carbon has
just the H is there so and specifically
this this base here is cytosine so now
what I want to do is I want to connect
these two specifically I want to connect
them here this 3 prime Oh H of the the
the DT MP is going to nucleophilic we
attack this phosphate the five prime
phosphate of of the dctp and then when
that happens the electrons from here
going to go onto this oh and then this
portion here this pyrophosphate will hop
off and then we will create a covalent
bond between this o and this P here and
that will yield this molecule so this is
the actual covalent bond that we've made
and that bond specifically is a
phosphodiester bond or phosphodiester
linkage and what is a phosphodiester
bond or a phosphodiester linkage well if
but if an ester bond looks like this
that is an ester functional group but
what a phosphodiester look like well
that would look like this would have a
phosphate with the carbonyl there and
then an O R and O R so this is a phospho
diester two ester linkages and
specifically it's a 3 prime to 5 prime
phosphodiester bond because the 3 prime
Oh H of the previous nucleotide
deoxynucleotide in this case is bound to
the five prime phosphate of the next one
so recall that this pyrophosphate hopped
off so we lose that pyrophosphate here
and this gets hydrolyzed off into two
inorganic phosphates so this reaction
requires the equivalent of two ATP
molecules now in this case these are
deoxy nucleotides that we're working
with here so this is going to be a DNA
strand right DNA dinucleotide this
reaction would be catalyzed by DNA
polymerase that's an enzyme you might
have heard about in a previous biology
course I wrote this over here
and I don't want this to confuse people
but if these were ribonucleotides then
it would have been done by RNA
polymerase
okay so I'm going to put a little
asterisk here okay and that would only
have been if these were ribonucleotides
okay so now over here this is our little
DNA strand now what if it was RNA
instead there would be two main
differences the first one is that of
course these two prime groups would be
OHS instead of just H's okay that's
something we've talked about in the
previous video in addition this is a T
the T nucleotide right has this little
methyl group here this methyl right is
the only difference between this in
uracil T's do not exist in RNA so there
would be no T's in RNA instead they
would just be used okay so if that was
the case we were making RNA RNA
polymerase will catalyze the reaction
this would have been an RNA strand
instead but this is the DNA strand okay
now I do want to mention one more thing
notice I've drawn this little dotted
gray line here I reason why I wanted to
do that was to separate this yellow
portion that I've drawn the these sugars
and the phosphate groups in from the
nitrogenous bases and the reason why is
because when we think about DNA and a
structure which we'll talk about more
depth in the next video is that it has
this the sugars and the phosphate kind
of make up what's called the backbone so
I want to label that here I'm going to
this side of the dotted line is going to
be the backbone specifically it's a
sugar phosphate backbone sugar phosphate
backbone and then the interior is this
portion here of course with a
nitrogenous bases we'll talk more about
that in detail in another video so
sometimes people will represent
single-stranded DNA like this a line to
represent I'd run it in the yellow to
indicate that that's the sugar phosphate
backbone and all of these little sort of
pink lines are present the nitrogenous
bases that are attached to the sugar
phosphate backbone so
I hope that video is helpful as far as
how to draw nucleic acids one last thing
I am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me at by
email at move University at gmail.com
for more information see the description
box below thank you for watching